by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself if you have a good dream
if you have a plan to making things
making progress
things will happen in the beginning
nobody wanted a tesla i can tell you
that
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one invest in yourself with warren
buffett
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself i mean that
for example communication skills i tell
the students that come that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas all that
if they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and in person
they increase their value at least 50
percent and now i mean
if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark
nothing happens you know basically and
and you have to be able to get
get both your ideas and uh and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course
some people wish i take it a shorter
course now in terms of my talking later
on
but it it's just hugely important and
you if you invest
in yourself nobody can take it away from
you rule number two
learn from everybody with jeff bezos the
most influential people in my life were
my grandparents and i have a my
mother had me when she was 17 years old
she raised me
with my grandparents help and she was
still in high school when she had me
that was not
cool in albuquerque new mexico in 1964
but she did an incredible job but i was
lucky because i had not just her
but i had she re she married my father
when i was about four years old he has
been a huge influence in my life
but my grandmother and grandfather were
like second set of parents for me
and you learn different things from them
because they're at a different stage of
life and they know different things
they're calm about certain things
it was a huge gift to me
my grandfather was a
had a ranch in texas and i spent all my
summers there from like age 4 to 16
and he was the most self-reliant person
he did all of his own veterinary work
all the things i mean and to
observe him solve problems and figure
out how to do things with no tools
and no resources and you know very small
amounts of money
it was a huge education from an early
age
so we're very like one of the things
that you i know people
who have uh they don't have
great family situations and
sometimes they break that cycle and they
are the ones who
pull out of it those people are the ones
i reserve my
highest admiration for rule number three
filter feedback with elon musk
in the beginning nobody wanted a tesla i
can tell you that
uh the the the
when we made the original sort of roads
to sports car
people like why would i want an electric
car that's my gasoline
car works fine i'm like no electric car
is better i should try it
and it was hard to get people to
do a test drive first one nobody knew
who we were
and then we heard this company and like
yeah we're named after nikola tesla you
know that guy nope
um so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said
there was no one telling us that they
wanted an electric car so it was not it
was not out of like
you know it was like lots of people
coming up to me saying hey i really want
electric car
i heard that zero times um
some people like it's like man we're
gonna make an electric car and show that
these things can be good
um and then people want them um
you know it's like i think it was like
henry ford said that like the you know
we're talking about the model t it's
like if you ask the public what they
wanted they'd say
a faster horse so if you did like a big
survey and say
well hey public before automobiles
what would you like it's like well i'd
like my horse to go three miles an hour
faster
and eat less food and uh
you know be stronger and live longer and
that kind of thing
there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse
um because people when you say like what
about an automobile that car that drives
itself like what are you talking about
that's not that sounds crazy um but
when you actually make an automobile and
give it to people and say okay
now this is a horse where you can keep
it in the barn and if you leave for a
month it's still alive
[Laughter]
yeah so carry more
more weight than a horse and go further
and that kind of thing so
anyway it's like when when it's a
radically
new product people don't know that they
want it because it's just not in their
in their scope i think when they first
started making tvs they did a nationwide
survey
i think this might have been like 46 or
48
it's like famous nationwide survey will
you ever buy a tv
now i was like 96 of respondents said no
some crazy number like basically
everyone's like would you buy a tv
and maybe they put a price in there or
something i don't know but it was
famously almost everyone said they would
not buy tv
but they didn't know what they're
talking about so the big game-changing
stuff at the beginning
is a company push kind of a thing most
of the time
but then changes to the product over
time can be
a lot more customer pull kind of a focus
yeah change changes to the product over
time can be
incremental changes um then
the customers can certainly tell you
it's good to get customer feedback to
say
how can we improve the product
and once they're using it they can say
okay i like this thing about it
i don't like this other thing and then
we can improve the product over time
customer feedback after they they have
the fundamental thing is is great also
if you want to have more self belief and
self confidence
i've designed a special free program to
help you
get it where i send you a video every
day
for 254 days the research says it can
take up to 254
days for you to build a new habit and
this program will help you get it once
again it's free
and the link to join is in the
description below they made us all these
crazy things to get out of ourselves and
so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things the
biggest risk you can take
is not taking any risk starting
companies like
staring into your bus and eating glass
rule number four
have strong beliefs with jack ma a great
entrepreneurs
should not have a money if you have a
money on mine this ice is us dollars
this is iron b and you're talking like
english pounds nobody
will work with like if you have a good
dream
if you have a plan to making things
making progress
things were happening and i changed my
mind to this morning just a
half an hour there i would do more
things in africa
and the only thing i want to do is not
to sell products here
and i will enable you to sell your
dreams all over the world in africa
supporting entrepreneurs is always my my
dream
because i know how tough it is to be an
entrepreneur
it is difficult i never cry i said i
only make my competitors cry
because if i cry i probably die a
hundred times
because we have to encourage our team
and i say making sure that we
that we can survive tomorrow as i said
before i answer a question i want to say
this is my belief
and this is what i tell every day to
myself today
is difficult tomorrow is much more
difficult but the day of tomorrow is
beautiful
most people die tomorrow evening even
today as my size
for our company's size i still believe
today is very difficult i have more
problems
than anybody here can imagine you say ah
now you are big
you make billions of dollars every you
know quarter
i have much more problems than you have
much more headache than you have rule
number five you are
what you believe with oprah winfrey
first day i went to school
i was in a classroom by the time i was
uh you know six years old didn't go to
school i was six years old because i
lived my grandmother at that time
but she had taught me how to read read
the bible bible stories
so i went into the classroom knowing
nicodemus
shadrach meshach and abednego i could
spell
all of those words i thought i was you
know i was preaching to the
to my kindergarten teacher so she was
like who is this girl
so i was never placed in an environment
where i was ever made to feel inferior
i always felt like i'm the smartest kid
in this room
and because i was never placed and it
never put in a position where i was made
to
feel less than i didn't grow up feeling
less than you know
and the rest as they say is history and
the rest they say is history
and it's all about what you believe you
know i say this to
uh when i do something on my network now
call life class
the fundamental key to success
is what you believe is true for yourself
not what you want not what you desire is
what do you believe
you know you can say i wanted i want to
be the most successful person in the
world
but if you believe that there's a glass
ceiling and you're going to have a hard
time
kicking through that glass ceiling you
will be defined by the glass ceiling
and um the great beauty and gift of my
life is that i was never
defined by the box that other people
tried to put me in
rule number six protect your ideas with
sarah bleakley
i didn't tell anybody my idea for one
whole year
and it's very important to tell the
people that can help move your idea
forward
but i didn't share it for validation
purposes and no one had shared that with
me it was sort of a gut feeling
but one you know ideas are the most
vulnerable in their
infancy the moment you have them and
this is the moment that we always want
to turn to a friend a co-worker
a husband and tell somebody the idea
well the minute you tell somebody the
idea ego has to get involved
and then you end up spending all of your
time defending it and explaining it
rather than pursuing it so
i feel like more than anything the
reason why i'm not still selling fax
machines is because i kept it a secret
for one whole year and all my friends
and family can tell you all i would ever
they would say is sarah's working on
some crazy invention we don't know what
it is
and after one year i sat them all down i
said okay guys
it's footless pantyhose i mean you
should have seen their faces like
and out of love and concern i heard you
know if it's such a good idea
why hasn't somebody else done it and
sweetie if it is such a good idea
you'd use your life savings and the big
guys might knock you out of the water in
six months
and until i'd invested this much of
myself
in this i think if i had heard that a
year ago when i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose that day
i'd still be selling fax machines and
rule number seven the last one before
very special bonus clip
is be clear with mark zuckerberg the
hardest thing for me
early on was because i i just started
off as i was
i was an engineer or you know i wasn't
even really an engineer as a student
right it's i i thought i was going to be
an engineer when i graduated
and you know when you're when you're
building something yourself
and you kind of have all the meetings in
your head right it's like you don't need
to articulate the principles so clearly
it's like you kind of can make all the
trade-offs on
on everything from architecture to
product to marketing to
you know just all these things and
you're kind of just you have the context
to trade this off
and i think it's really easy
when you start building something to
um to underestimate
how much context you need to put out
there and how clear you need to be about
what you're trying to do so
you know most of my mistakes early on in
building the company
were about not being clear enough
internally about what we were trying to
do and there's this
very famous episode where
we're like in 2006 a couple years into
building the company
yahoo tried to buy us and so they
offered a ton of money
and a lot of the people who who i'd
hired at the point they were kind of
experienced
technology executives and this was like
all of their startup dream come true
right they joined and then
you know within you know a year or a few
months like the the company
had the opportunity to exit for this
large amount of money
and you know i really
failed through that period to
communicate what we were trying to do
and what we
what we stood for and
in the absence of that that context
then of course it was a rational thing
for people to think that this was like a
good outcome for us to have
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you going to
take action on it
this week when you schedule in what day
what time
and what place you're going to take
action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan and when
you share your plan publicly and have
some accountability you increase your
chances even further
of actually following through so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
if you had to define the american dream
what would you say
it is that when you think
that there's all the opportunity you
want and you don't know any better
you go after it in my generation it was
a pleasure work
whether it was at the variety boys club
at seven years old making flower pots
going on selling them or
christmas cards at nine or uh going on
the streets at
11 years old delivering morning
newspapers
for us it was fun to work now what do we
do with the money we gave to my mom so
we have a better way of life
we got into high school my brother and i
saved a little bit of it
for our car which happened to be a
junker but we rebuilt it in auto shop
but because we for us it was a pleasure
to work you know just because wow we got
a job it was so cool
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below
or if you want even more insight into
how billionaires think check out the
video right there next to me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there